I remember the first time I jumped in I
was scared to death you know that as the
the power to mangle you in a second
but it chooses not to and that
fascinates me my name is Andres bhai de
I'm a sailor adventurer and marine
biologist from Norway this is my third
season in northern Norway where I spent
the winter with my poster barbra it's
harsh and it's also tremendously
beautiful
there is no sign of people to me it's
nature at its very best
our goal for this season is to make a
documentary about orchids and whales in
the wild what makes the interaction with
all get so special is that you know that
it's the apex predator of the sea has a
tremendous power often we have to
observe them from this and at some point
they are relaxed and you can approach
them and that's when you get them
playful they're so gentle yet so fast
and they're so powerful yet so very calm
and peaceful to me these whales and the
era they're in they're kind of the
pinnacle of interacting with nature once
you've made eye contact with an orca
there is no turning back the moment you
never forget
[Music]